[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK CHMARNY: Welcome.
Thank you for coming.
I know this is the
first session the day
after a conference party.
So it's not always
heavily packed,
but thank you for coming.
My name is Mark Chmarny.
I'm one of the serverless
technical program
managers looking after
Serverless at Google.
TOMAS ISDAL: And
I'm Tomas Isdal.
I'm imaging manager at Google.
MARK CHMARNY: How many of you
have been here a year ago when
we did the introductory or the
announcement of Knative launch?
Good numbers.
But we have also a fair
amount of new faces.
And I think that speaks to
some of the exciting momentum
in the community around Knative.
So we will have
a few slides kind
of talking about the
momentum of the project
and the kind of growth
of the community.
And definitely want to
dedicate some time on the end
to questions, because usually
these kind of sessions
spark a fair amount of those.
So the session is called
Knative A Year Later,
but the reality, it's really
just been nine months.
There is magic of conference
scheduling that happens there.
And what an exciting and very
fun ride that has been for us.
And I think just watching from
the announcements to the growth
has being really, really good.
So a year ago-- just a little
flashback for those of you who
have not been here--
a year ago, we talked about
the fact that already then,
in fact, probably even
before then, Kubernetes
was the de facto platform
for running containers
at a lot of different places.
Like, at that point,
it was already
hard to find a cloud
service provider that
was not offering Kubernetes
as a service at that time.
And that speaks to the kind of
proliferation of that platform
everywhere.
We also at the time
when we started
kicking off thinking
about Knative,
we were looking across
the community and we saw--
the number is 13
here, but frankly,
who knows how many there
really were out there--
different projects that
were focused on building
serverless offering
or serverless platform
on top of Kubernetes in
an open source community.
And the interesting
part was that they
were focusing a lot of attention
on very complex and kind of,
to some degree, almost
boring problems that
had to be addressed with regards
to running inside of Kubernetes
for different types of workloads
that Kubernetes was originally
designed for.
So in addition to kind of
trying to solve some of the user
experience, they had to
address the building of images,
the routing, managing
the scaling, and stuff
like that, stuff that was not
really exposed to the user.
In the process of doing that, in
the process of really building
all these new platforms, because
if you ask four engineers to do
something, there will be
five different ways to do it,
they end up building
very hard-to-reproduce or
nonportable solutions
that were hard to leverage
for the community.
So not only they were
decreasing the portability
of those projects
by working together
on the same set of
problems, they were also--
given that the resources,
the engineering resources,
are limited--
they were not investing a lot
of attention towards areas
that the developer actually
could benefit from.
So the overall
experience, the new event
sources, the different
run times, and so forth.
So at last Next, we announced
Knative as an open source--
set of open source
Building Blocks
for building a serverless
solution on Kubernetes.
And I stress the Building
Blocks, because initially we
were really focusing on making
sure that each one of those
can be used independently
to allow developers to build
products for their developers.
And the initial set of work
was around Knative buildings,
eventing, and serving.
So let's kind of look
where we are today.
Today, I'm happy to announce
that not only has Building
Blocks been very successful
and continue evolving,
but there is now a series
of commercial offerings
that are based on top of
Knative Building Blocks.
Different companies that are
listed over here, including you
might have heard this week about
the exciting launch of Cloud
Run and Cloud Run on GKE that
we have talked about over here.
But in addition to
that, there's a number
of other commercial
offerings, both as a service
and as a product that different
companies use the components
that Knative enables to
build their offerings on top
of Kubernetes.
So let's go quickly and just
overview where we are today.
I think what I'm
talking about here
is set of features
and capabilities
that we provide that
were available in a 0.5
release of Knative, which
landed just this week.
And in fact, there
is a blog that
was published this morning
that you can kind of get
a quick update on what
new features specifically
are on eventing that
were added over there.
But in area of serving, what
are the benefits for developer?
First of all, and the one
that we hear the most about,
is the notion of
auto-scaling, being
able to scale your
application and respond
to unpredictable usage patterns.
So no longer thinking about
what my size of my audience
is going to be or going
in manually adding
nodes, but having that
solution or the system
that you're building on top
using Knative automatically
scale and address the demand.
But also when that demand
is no longer there,
being able to scale
to 0 and allow
you to use the resources
in your Kubernetes
cluster for other
work that might
be important at that time.
So really greatly benefiting
the overall utilization
of the cluster.
The other important part that
we talk about a lot of times
is the notion of snapping both
the configuration and the code
at the same time and being
able to reliably use it
for individual deployments,
which is great, because you
write all perfect code.
But when I have a
bug, I sometimes
need to go roll back
to last previous known
state or some version that
I know actually works.
So being able to manage
revisions and configuration
as a unit is critical for that.
Knative comes with a very
powerful tool underneath,
the Istio Mesh Network.
And sometimes it can be
pretty complex for developers.
So Knative exposes that as a
set of very simple set of APIs
that allows you to manage
things like request path access
control or being able to expose
certain metrics from that Istio
Mesh, but not
having have to force
you to configure this manually,
which can be complex at times.
And there's a number
of other features.
The other part about
Knative serving
is that it is very pluggable.
And what we mean by
that is that in case
of Google, what
we've done is when
we built Knative-compatible
service, the Cloud Run on GKE
and Cloud Run, we can integrate
with native services that
are offered on GCP that offer
things like building so you can
build source code all the way
to Container or Stackdriver
or other services for data
persistence and analytics.
In addition to that,
it's also extendable.
So we've talked about
number of partners.
The two I want to highlight
over here is GitLab--
I think we have a session
later today that will
highlight one of their demos--
that use continuous deployment
and integration demonstration
of how they connect
to the Knative APIs
as well as Datadog for
some of the metrics
that you can do as an
alternative to Stackdriver.
So exciting things in Serving.
In Build, from the
very beginning,
Knative was able to off
a reproducible build.
And that sounds very
simple, but when
you think about being
able to reliably-- sorry.
This morning, I'm
struggling with English--
reliably built images
from the same code,
including things like
timestamps and others
that give you the same
image over and over again,
it's something that
I think, if you've
done some builds yourself
before you will quickly
realize it's not easy.
The other thing that Knative
Build provides is series
of pipelines or different
language-optimized frameworks
that can be used to build
directly from source and either
result in an image that then
you manually deploy or actually
help you go all the way
from source to URL--
to live active URL.
All of that is
done on a cluster.
So there is no need
for Docker locally.
There's no need for
cross-compiling.
So if you're working
on a Mac or Windows,
and you need to build an image
that's going to run on Linux,
which Knative runs today on, you
don't have to deal with those
and remember all the extra
flags and how to do that.
And some of the dynamic
languages, for example,
might have to benefit
from that too.
And because this is
running as a service,
it's running on the clusters,
running on top of Kubernetes,
you're benefiting from a lot of
the elasticity and being able
to use the resources when you
need them and dedicating those
resources to something
else when you don't.
Again, loosely coupled,
you will see that theme
across every one of the
components of Knative.
So in this case,
integrates with a number
of different CI/CD tools.
I think if you've attended the
Cloud Run Solutions yesterday,
I demonstrated a Cloud
Build integration.
We have Jenkins X,
a number of others,
including a new foundation
that we launched specifically
to kind of focus on that
that leverages that Knative--
originally launching in
Knative is the Continuous Build
Foundation.
And there is growing
number of Enterprise tools
that are kind of popping
up here that provide
some very specific set of
features for Enterprise use
cases, like policy management,
logging, and so forth.
So again, so Serving, Build,
and last but not least,
always Eventing for some
reason ends up on the end.
I don't know why
that's the case.
We need to flip the
order sometimes.
So Eventing, super exciting
set of add-ons in the 0.5
release that we just
launched this week,
kind of adding to the very
primitive set of objects
that we have had
underneath and adding
some easier-to-use constructs
like Broker and Trigger
that developers
can easily just use
by leveraging some
of the defaults
that Knative already exposed.
What Knative Eventing
does, by default, is
helps you really orchestrate
the event sources and events,
both on the cluster as
well as off the cluster.
It provides a very declarative
way of binding to event sources
and connecting them to
either directly some consumer
of the sources but also building
very complex set of pipelines
that you get in.
Those little pipelines get more
interesting and interesting
as people get creative
with how you can
leverage those capabilities.
Because it runs on
Knative and it's not just
a brand-new set
of things, it just
leverages the Knative
architecture and components,
you're getting the exact same
scalability and other scaling
capabilities that
you've seen in Serving.
So you can build things that
are very nominal in a resource
utilization when you
first deploy them
and you use them but
automatically address
a larger number of
events when you need to.
And all of that is
based with regards
to transport on standards,
cloud events for kind
of packaging the events.
So what that means, that we
are able to attach ourselves
to a number of other
different projects
and event sources
that generate events
in this new open
standard for events.
Again, loosely
coupled or extendable
so you can bind to
existing event sources.
There's probably
28, 23, or something
like that of different--
I know, I went down.
I shouldn't have gone down.
The list grows all the time.
And you can see that full
list of existing event sources
that you don't have to
build, you can just consume,
on Knative website.
But we also provide a very
easy way of extending those,
and there is a whole
session later today, SRV305,
that you can come to that is
dedicated explicitly to the new
Eventing sources and [INAUDIBLE]
is going to talk about the new
object models--
hopefully not
business-- and share
some of the hands-on ways of
building new event sources.
All right.
So that was about the
capabilities of Knative.
Let's talk about community.
Frankly, we could not
have done this ourselves,
and there is a pretty
fascinating community already
behind Knative, starting
with the launch partners
nine months ago.
So let's overview.
Today, again, 0.5
already landed.
Our community has 49, 50--
I think more now
since yesterday.
These numbers are probably
from Friday, I think--
50 different companies that
are contributing to Knative.
Over 3.7 thousand
different pull requests.
The number of contributors,
and what I mean by contributors
is not only people who
write code, but also people
who review code, people
who write documentation,
400-plus of those.
The one interesting
number here is also
we have now spun off nine
different work groups.
So these are kind of
specific area interest groups
that are, like, you know what?
I cannot understand
the entire Knative,
but in the area of auto-scaling,
I think I can contribute,
and I can be a
valuable resource.
And people from a number
of different companies,
including those who
would never write code,
that's contributed to Knative.
Come in and join us on that.
The number that I am
most interested about,
though, probably most proud
of, is that the momentum,
it wasn't just when
we launched it.
It continued being sustained.
So I build this kind of
20% month-over-month number
by aggregating the pull
requests, the issues,
the comments, the Slack channel
participation, work group
participation, just
seeing this line growing.
Tomas is going to talk a
little later about what that
means in engineering terms.
It's just fascinating.
All right.
The other interesting number
with regards to community
is that, yeah, Google was
there in the beginning and some
of their launch
partners, and we are
extremely thankful
for those partners
and their participation in that.
But just the long
tail of companies
that are now
contributing to Knative
is something that speaks to
the health of the project.
One fifth of all
contributions to Knative
are done by the broad
community, people
who have less than 15 different
PRs, I think, at this point.
There's a link to
the live stats.
So these numbers
change all the time.
You can look it up.
But that's just fascinating that
this long tail of contributors
drives really the momentum,
because different companies
getting involved in
this project means
that the number of use
cases that they address
is also growing.
And that drives features
back into Knative,
which speaks further
to the capabilities
that we can do with this.
I'm going to hand it to Tomas
to talk about engineering.
TOMAS ISDAL: Thank
you very much.
Thanks, Mark.
Super exciting to
see so many companies
contribute to the system.
And I think it
speaks to how useful
these small primitives
that we have built
and how useful these companies
find these primitives.
We see a lot of
momentum in Knative,
and we talked a lot
about the open source,
but we see this in
customer growth.
We see this in partners
launching services
on top of Knative.
And we're seeing
it in the number
of contributors to the
project and the amount of code
they write.
So just in the last
quarter, we had 228 people
contributing to Knative.
And these folks
wrote over 1,500 PRs.
That's five times more than
what we had in Q2 2018.
So amazing growth.
And my team at Google,
we're writing a lot of this,
around 61%.
And we plan to
continue investing
in Knative to keep
this acceleration going
into next year.
But as an engineering
manager, you
know that just writing
a bunch of code
is not enough to have a
healthy open source project.
There's a lot of other
things you have to do.
So what we have done
as well is to grow up
as an open source community.
We have created a
steering committee
that's in charge of
the overall health
and long-term sustainability
of the project.
And we have recently
invited non-Google members
to the steering committee.
This is how we create
the robust ecosystem.
It can't be a single vendor when
we have 50 companies that are
partnering for a shared goal.
We have a technical
oversight committee
that's doing a similar thing
from a technical perspective.
Other things that we
have done is related
to this promise of portability.
We want to make sure the code
you write for Knative will
work, of course on Cloud Run,
but it also works in Knative
to open source, in your own
data center, or on a competitor.
And the way we do this is
to clearly, clearly define
the expectations of the
system and have tests
that verify that the
implementations meet
those specifications.
I also want to highlight that we
have software engineers working
on Knative, but
we also have folks
working on test infrastructure
documentation, samples,
et cetera.
I'm really proud about
how solid the engineering
work is on Knative and
how good our releases are.
My team knows that I'm a
stickler for flaky tests.
I really don't like flaky tests.
And for a long time,
we had 0% flaky tests,
which wasn't true,
because it rounded down.
So it was actually
0.04% test flakes.
But it was still what you need.
If we have 200 people from 50
companies contributing code,
and you want to
have any reassurance
that that code
actually works, you
need to have a really, really
solid test infrastructure.
And that's something we
have invested in a lot.
Similarly, we have a team
writing documentation
and samples so that your
developers at your companies
can read how to get started
with Knative from a developer
point of view and from a
contributor point of view.
So what do we get with 400
contributors and thousands--
4,000 pull requests?
Well, we have done a
lot over the last year.
It's pretty incredible to think
that just a year ago, less
than a year ago, is when
we briefed a few partners
under NDA at KubeCon
in Copenhagen.
And nine months ago, we
launched at Cloud Next.
And we got a lot of
excitement, which is great.
We were super excited to
see that we hit a nerve.
A lot of people had been
thinking about the same thing,
and they wanted someone to
come in and really, really
rally the community
around a shared goal.
But we also got a
lot of criticism.
And that's even better,
because that means that people
care about what you're doing.
And we took this
criticism to heart.
So we spent quite a lot of
time between 0.1 and 0.2
to re-architect the system to
make it more flexible and more
pluggable so that partners can
fit this into the environment
where they're working.
So at 0.2, we sort of had
the foundation in place
to have something really useful.
And the product
shifted at that point
from addressing partner
needs, infrastructure needs,
architecture, to
addressing customer needs.
And we saw that in 0.3.
We had the support for the
container resource spec.
And this is largely driven by
requests for GPUs and TPUs.
A lot of people want to
run machine learning models
or machine learning
serving on Knative and GPUs
make that a lot cheaper.
People wanted to run
private Knative services.
So we added support for
private or public services.
So you can do, depending
on your front-end
is open to the public,
your back end is hidden.
And you don't want
that to be accessible
to the broad internet.
And of course, improved all
the scaling, improved scale
to 0, all those things.
At this point, we also
changed our release model.
So we're now every six
weeks cutting a new release.
And that's how we get features
out to customers quickly.
Of course, bug fixes, security
fixes go out every week.
But major changes go
out every six weeks.
And this allows us to take
feedback from customers.
So in 0.4, the feedback
had shifted a little bit.
From 0.3 was, OK, we can't
do what we need to do.
0.4 was, hey, I'm
running Knative,
and it turns out that upgrading
to the next version of Knative,
which by the way, you now
have to do every six weeks,
is really annoying.
It takes a lot of time.
So we spent a lot of
time between 0.3 and 0.4
to make that into a seamless
experience for people
running on top of Knative.
And also because we run
Knative services ourselves,
Cloud Run NGK and Cloud Run.
And we want to make sure
that those systems can
upgrade smoothly as well.
We also added more
support for things
we hear from Enterprises.
They are really
careful about how
they manage secrets for how they
authenticate to other services.
Kubernetes has support for this.
We forwarded the
support into Knative.
Similarly, once you
start architecting system
with a front end and
private back end,
so you want to have a really
efficient communication
channel.
So we added the support
for HTP2 and gRPC
so that you can have this
efficient communication channel
between your microservices.
And now, just last
week we cut it,
announced it today,
0.5 gRPC streaming
and then a big
overhaul in Eventing.
So really, really huge
improvements there.
At 1:15 today, we're going to
do a deep dive into Knative
Eventing, and I really
recommend that session.
So I'm going to invite
Ryan Gregg up on stage.
And he's going to talk about how
you can use Knative on Google
Cloud to make your
developers more
productive for your business.
RYAN GREGG: Good morning.
Oh, hey.
Cool.
So I'm Ryan Gregg.
I'm a product manager on the
Serverless Team at Google.
And this week we were really
excited to announce the launch
into beta for both Cloud
Run and Cloud Run on GKE.
Yeah, where did that-- come on.
Let's everybody wake
up a little bit here.
[APPLAUSE]
There we go.
All right.
I'm not below begging for
people to applaud for me.
[LAUGHTER]
Last year, when I
announced Knative,
I got applause for building
Hello World in Docker.
So, like, I'm all for it.
So Cloud Run and
Cloud Run GKE, these
are our managed
Knative offerings.
And Cloud Run is a fully
managed serverless platform
for running containers on Google
Serverless infrastructure.
So you get the Knative API,
you get the Knative Runtime
Contract.
But you don't have to worry
about the cluster or any
of the implementation
details under the covers
or even what version of
Knative you're running.
You just get to call the API,
deploy a container, and go.
And the best part about Cloud
Run is that it's pay-for-use.
You only have to
pay for the time
that the request
is being processed.
And the rest of the time,
when we scale the service down
or even if we don't, it's free.
Cloud Run on GKE gives you a
lot more flexibility, though.
It's actually running the
Knative open source components
along with some additional
work on top of your Kubernetes
and in cluster.
So you can go in and
use the Knative API
to deploy workloads.
You can use the great UI and CLI
that we offer through G Cloud
and through Cloud Console,
or you can go into the API
and do all of the
Kubernetes stuff
that you're used to
being able to do.
You can access the
Knative API directly.
You can program Istio
under the covers
to add policies to the
workloads that you're deploying.
And you can take advantage of
the additional resources that
are available in GKE, like more
memory, more CPU types, GPUs,
and TPU accelerators, all the
greatness of compute that is
available on Kubernetes Engine.
And then, of course, you
can use Knative anywhere.
So in addition to the managed
products through Anthos
or on-prem offering and on
basically any Kubernetes
cluster anywhere, of
course, you can run Knative
and have a great story for
being able to use our serverless
experience across all
three environments.
So wherever you go, you can have
a great serverless experience.
We also have a
bunch of customers
who've been using us
in the alpha program,
and it's been really
exciting to see the workloads
that they have
built. For example,
we worked with Airbus
Aerial to do an alpha test
on Cloud Run on GKE,
and they used it
for doing real-time
processing of imagery that
comes from drones,
airplanes, and satellites
to help understand the
impact of disaster areas
and be able to respond quickly.
And they're really
excited about the way
that the serverless
platform scales,
because as it turns
out, you can't really
predict when natural
disasters are going to happen.
And you need to be able to
respond really quickly and have
the infrastructure
scale up underneath it.
And with Cloud Run
and Cloud Run on GKE,
they really saw
some great benefits
for being able to respond
to natural disasters
when they occurred.
So those are our
two different ways
of running managed Knative
on top of Google Cloud.
We're really excited
to see what everybody
is going to be building
on top of them,
in addition to how you continue
to use the Knative Open Source
project.
Thanks, Tomas.
Thanks, Mark.
TOMAS ISDAL: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
Really exciting to see that.
To summarize what we've
talked about so far,
so Mark started by talking
a little bit about what
Knative does and how it can
make your developers more
productive.
Then we talked a little
bit about the broad uptake
in the open source
community and how
we're trying to foster a really
healthy long-term sustainable
community for Knative.
I talked a little bit about
what we did last year.
And I want to just
give a hint of what
we see happening in the
immediate future for Knative.
So we just cut 0.5, and
0.5 is a great milestone.
But the real important
milestone is 1.0.
That's when people can put
their mission-critical,
business-critical logic
on top of Knative.
And quite honestly,
we're not there just yet.
So where I see the team
going and the community going
is that we really need to
double down on get to 1.0.
What we have right
now, it's super-useful.
It has enough functionality
to be a really viable product.
But we don't really have the
performance and stability
just yet that you can put
your 1.0 brand behind.
The other thing we
need to focus on
is to get an API that we're
comfortable standing behind
for years.
We have made some changes
throughout the last year,
based on customer feedback.
That's why you have a
0.1, 0.2, 0.3, right?
We're bringing those
changes in, and we
have a really focused
working group right now
to get the 1.0 API draft out.
And if you're interested
in contributing,
we really value feedback
in these working groups.
And they're open to the public.
And if you go to
our GitHub page,
you can see how you can
join these meetings.
I touched a little
bit on specifications.
And the broader term there,
I would call it conformance.
Ryan was talking about
Knative anywhere.
That only works if
we have a robust set
of conformance and
conformance tests
that we can run to make sure
that this Knative deployment is
conformant with the
Knative standard.
That's a big focus for the team.
If you really love writing
tests, we have work for you.
MARK CHMARNY: Who doesn't?
TOMAS ISDAL: Just ping
me, and I'll send you
a bunch of tests to write.
So these are things
that we're doing.
Of course, we're
going to continue
to address customer feedback.
We're going to continue
to add features,
but that's not the biggest
focus in the project right now.
The biggest focus is to get to
1.0, because in my mind, that's
when the fun starts.
That's when people
start using your things.
That's when you have the
customer, the big, big customer
growth.
And the reason
we're doing this is
because we want to help
other people be more
productive in this business.
And that doesn't really happen
until we get to GA and 1.0.
So we talked a little
bit about last year
we were seeing
that Kubernetes was
becoming the de facto platform
for running containers.
And last year
Knative didn't exist.
I hope now, through the
keynotes and the samples
and the products that
Google has launched,
plus the five other products
other cloud providers have
launched, we have
convinced you that Knative
is becoming the de facto
platform for running serverless
and Kubernetes.
With that, we have a
little bit of time.
Oh, yeah.
We have talked a
lot about Knative.
I highlighted a
few sessions here.
We mentioned that there is a
Knative Eventing SVR305 coming
this afternoon at 1:15 PM.
These other sessions will
be available on YouTube
to watch in case
you missed them.
We're at the tail end
of the conference.
So it's too late to
go through them now.
But you can watch
them on YouTube.
I recommend double speed.
It's the way to do it.
MARK CHMARNY: When
we talk, yeah.
TOMAS ISDAL: Yeah.
So thank you so much.
This is how you can contact us.
Please join the open
source community.
Join.
You can be one of a thousand
people in our Slack channel.
It's beautiful.
And thank you so much for all
of the people in the room who
might have contributed and
the industry partners that
have partnered with us
to make this successful.
MARK CHMARNY: And
now with Cloud Run--
[APPLAUSE]
MARK CHMARNY: Now with
Cloud Run being generally
available to everybody, you can
easily just take it for a spin.
TOMAS ISDAL: Beta available.
Available to the public.
MARK CHMARNY: It's easily
available on GCP, yes.
It's not generally available.
TOMAS ISDAL: It's
available, yeah.
MARK CHMARNY: There you go.
You can easily try-- how about
that-- using this Cloud Run
URL there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]